hello there reject nation I'm Greg Alba
I'm John Humphrey we finally have it
debuting online the mandalorian trailer
let's watch it
[Music]
oh wow
[Music]
Oh awesome
[Music]
yes
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
whoa yeah that road is complicated
oh nice dude I wonder if he's gonna take
off oh it was great
that was a great can't can't lie about
it oh that western vibe you know how
like dusty and sperrit looks and
everything I mean like it has all the
crazy Star Wars designer II but it just
has such a different sort of tone about
it like I love that whispering wind
feels like dark a little ominous they
said it was like inspired by like yeah
what spaghetti westerns but also not
Karyn Kusama damn dude oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah the Seven Samurai you could
definitely feel those tones throughout I
love how dark it is oh you know what I'm
more excited for this than rising
Skywalker I am - this looks so damn good
yeah when this looks like an expansion
on the world like this looks like a new
Star Wars story doesn't look reminiscent
of the yeah Star Wars source and I
wonder if he's gonna take off the mask
because it kind of did I get a little
bit of dread vibe I know ever been like
wouldn't it be cool if he just kept it
on the entire I mean I I don't think you
will I don't know it's Pedro Pascal and
he's such an amazing actor and he's so
great for dialogue and he's a handsome
devil - yeah - you at least see like the
bottom half of his face yeah there's
also bad the action looks great and I've
heard is like 10 million dollars in
episode you guys feel that production as
I'm here - yeah I feel like they're
really gonna utilize her actors are they
I really highlighted Werner Herzog and
Carl Weathers as grief oh man oh I'm
excited as he hurts I never expected to
see Hertzog in the Star Wars universe of
all places and you got like some
familiar Star Wars imagery with some of
the creatures which you know also like
see the aliens not the carpet for
getting in right now the thing that
haunts all haunts all that was frozen in
carbonite I love like the despair and
the horrors after war because it takes
place after we turn the Jedi before for
some weekends so you're at a very
specific time period where it's like the
rise of the first order that opening
shot of all those stormtroopers heads on
spy
that's our rating yet I suppose yeah but
but it feels like there's kind of a
violent menacing tone about it also
seeing a lot of the new weapons up I
mean the Galleon kind of gun that he has
they're so so cool and this also looks
like both a cool expansion from a
character universe story point of view
but it also looks like an expansion and
just like how cool stars positively be
because I feel like the thing is like
that mask that out flag you know the
Mandalorian look armor is so cool right
yeah like you know you toss in a Gatling
gun or some kind of other weapon it's
gonna look awesome but this just looks
really physical like I like that even
there is still mystery I don't know
exactly what the plotline of the show is
gonna be but you know you've got this
seedy underworld
you see a little bit of how he fights as
much as I am unnerved by the way
sometimes you know pg-13 things get
around it this looks relatively intense
without you know breaching that line you
know he's about to slice that dude's
head off with that door yeah or slice
him in half or something and you also
got some glimpses of ig-88 who's an
empire taiko yt.timing it's gonna be the
same voice yeah we got to hike before
this lot give you some humor infused but
it seemed I I get some slide out what
they'll do with it is a little bit of
k2s oh think worries like gonna be funny
but he's also gonna be a badass at the
same time yeah the kind of humor you'd
see in Western yeah this this feels like
a more dirty grimy world I love the this
seems like it'll have like some slow
moving parts to it that'll really work
on delivering tension which does harken
back to like a little bit of Sergio
Leone any kind of western films when
they said Western I wasn't sure how much
they were committing to that but this
reeks of Judas I 5 Star Wars West you
got a shot of a hand on a trigger
tapping it yeah another dude in the
background like this is very well just a
standoff at the bar with
with our Mandalorian character yeah
they're also I don't you know I don't
know where any of these images yeah yeah
there's a lot of traveling in Star Wars
anyway but at least it's just the the
vague vibe I'm taking off of this
trailer is like maybe we're gonna follow
him to a lot of different places maybe
each episodes gonna have you know sort
of disparate characters like I don't
know how what I'm sure there's a
serialized element but I'm also curious
as to whether we're gonna kind of see
some more one-off characters things like
that something that's not so well I mean
like I don't know how much footage just
is pulling from in terms of the whole
first a minute is there's the whole
season because there's only like a
glimpse of a moment in space yeah and
it's inspired from Star Wars but I like
that it feels very much grounded right
now oh yeah totally well you know you
got to get on a train sometimes in a
Western you know that's what your space
travel is when your horses are the big
creatures I can't wait to check it out
beautiful cinematography throughout they
look like they're really doing something
different all right guys well is this
delivering on expectation for you so far
comment below you guys can subscribe to
the reel rejects click that notification
bell you can check us out on patreon
where we do weekly Q&A s TV show
reaction stream along some shows of
reaction highlights included I'd like to
give a page from the day shout out to a
man named David Gandy Marlin Gando David
my friend my buddy you were under way to
becoming a badass Mandalorian warrior of
sorts one might say the man to Laurie
oh yeah well he's training so much in
martial arts right now but he still has
a generous heart but I feel that
darkside coming out of you man I feel
that evil lurking within you I want you
to unleash it man I want you to go to
the streets and pick a fight as soon as
you can just go into your garage have
one of those montages where you like
pound yourself out like your own mask
put it on all slow and then just walk
out and start you know messing things up
you know get out the people show them
that an 80 year old man can still kick a
lot of behind
I gotta edit this look we're done